hello yawn and magnus um great game
today another draw who would have
guessed my name is andrea reporting from
botezz live magnus i bet you're really
tired of getting a lot of really
complicated chess questions but i've
been dying to ask you how does the
knights move
um that's uh that's a good uh good
question uh it generally moves
like an l and sometimes in blitz games
it can be very unpredictable thank you
magnus only you could answer my question
hi this is anna kremling reporting from
my channel under kremling and this is a
question for both players if you could
only play e4 or d4 for the rest of your
lives which move of the two would you
choose and why
thank you um yeah it's a little bit
different from from other questions
thank you um
i would probably
probably go for um for e4
seems like there's
a little more variety
there
in both closed and open games
but um
uh
otherwise i i um
i'm i'm thinking that um
it's probably probably um enough theory
that we have already and it's difficult
enough to
to get an opening advantage so to
actually be restricted to only one move
would be
a bit of a nightmare
well
i guess
100 years ago or about it someone
yes rouser thought that okay wine just
wins after the first movie four
so
quite some
something
changed since then but uh yeah in
general overall it feels like
e4 is nowadays is more forcing but um
at the same time you know that
i would say more fun so let's be for
okay thank you
chess.com again i'll also try my hand at
a non-topical question for once uh if
either of you could choose any second in
history to be on your current team that
is any player
that's ever been alive to be on your
current team who would it be and why
questions for both players yeah
i'm pretty satisfied with the team i
have
um
i'm also very satisfied with
the team
that i have
but
maybe kramnik in 96 he seemed to be a
good second for uh for gary
probably pretty annoying but still very
interesting
why would he be annoying
i think that's self-explanatory
we just have one more question from feed
hs twitter page you can send your
questions in and you may get hear them
here on the air
magnus to you do you plan on sharing any
of your birthday cake with team nepo
[Laughter]
uh yeah that's uh that's a weird
question um
first of all i don't know if i'll have
any uh maybe a little bit tomorrow um
but um
i i i think with the history of world
championship matches
i don't think you would uh
accept any piece of food from the
opposing team
ever
well obviously
i could defend better but in general i
felt like uh
okay
uh for quite some time i was right i was
regretting of playing b5
although i think uh
after bishop h3ok there is like
capturing on f7 some rookie i believe
some rookie check or something yes so
but rookie rook g6
sorry rookie a8 there's rook g6
so i mean but i need to check screen a7
yeah i i mean i take with the queen
because if i take with the bishop and
rookie eight there is rook g6
no but which moment
bishop h7 if rookie eight king h7 bishop
f7 there's rookies well again like uh
queen e3 okay queen if we check king
jade
prince xa7 yeah quintex seven bishops
which is free and if rookie check rookie
eight king h7 takes on f7 error bishop
seven rockets
okay
it would be something but i also have
was kind of not sure about queen takes
if someone yeah this is probably what i
have to have to do yeah but no i mean
okay indeed i didn't um
i didn't play
at my best after after blunder but it
was
a little bit hard to you know to
change
uh
the you know the flow of the game
because it was like uh
probably
in a very drawish position of course
it's like blundering upon like this it
hurts
stockfish 14 with nu seems to possess
this game as two average center pawn
loss versus three average center pawn
loss
which in our assessment so far seems to
have been the most accurate according to
engines game ever played in chess world
championship history
um can i ask you both perhaps starting
with magnus how it feels to have played
what seems to be one of the most
accurate games uh to have been played so
far in world championship history
according to engines
uh well uh thank you very much uh it
feels feels great uh it fills me with uh
with uh with pride uh uh but
unfortunately only half a point on the
on the score table sure and yeah i said
it's quite a murky question before the
dropping test
[Laughter]
thank you very much thanks you said that
you could live without the world
championship uh when you consider
your incumbency do you think one day
that you'll be able to leave it
on your own terms
or do you believe that uh one day
you might be left helpless in your seat
as you have left all the other champions
that you've played since 2013. thank you
um yeah thank you
first of all um that's um
it's a very good question
i cannot answer it right now
[Music]
you